- [Voiceover] Dear BuzzFeed,
this is how I look with makeup
and this is how I look without makeup.
My name is Shalom.
I grew up in Nigeria where my
family owns a fast food store.
When I was nine years old
my sister and I fell asleep
under the table where my
mother fries food we sold.
We were fast asleep when the hot oil above
suddenly fell pouring all
over my face and body.
I remember screaming and crying
as my family poured water on us,
and my burning flesh
falling on the ground.
I spent four months in the hospital.
My eyes couldn't open, and my
fingers couldn't straighten.
When I returned to
school I quickly realized
life after the incident wasn't
what I thought it would be.
Kids would bully and stare at me.
Sometimes they even ran away
because my face scared them.
They called me burned face, two face,
scarface and so on.
I felt like a living statue
for people to come see.
Then I discovered makeup
tutorials on YouTube.
I watched hours upon hours of videos
to learn how to do makeup
and soon I was good,
and my classmates started asking me
to do their makeup for them.
But I still didn't feel happy.
Soon I started having suicide thoughts.
Eventually I came across Talia Joy,
a beautiful girl on
YouTube fighting cancer
and like me she didn't have any hair.
I was amazed by her courage
to come on camera without a wig.
On June 17, 2014 I
posted a photo of myself
without a wig on Instagram
for the first time.
To my surprise people were
positive and encouraging,
and said my photo inspired
them to also be bold.
I felt like a load was
taken off of my shoulders
because I was finally being honest
and not giving a crap
what anyone has to say
about my appearance.
This lead to me wanting
to share more with people,
because if Talia could do it, so could I.
And if I can, anyone can.
So I decided to start
my own beauty channel
because I wanted to help
other people like me,
not only to learn how to do makeup,
but to learn to love themself
for who they truly are.
Makeup is not the reason why I'm happy,
it is something I enjoy doing.
I'm happy because I've
learned to love myself.
I'm happy that I can be myself
and share my passion with the world.
As you can see this is
how I look with makeup
and without makeup,
and I love both of the sides equally.